let's go next to hayden
from morgantown west virginia hayden
from morgantown west virginia you are on
what is on your mind uh not much um i
just want to ask you some questions
about down ballot races
sure yeah so currently like out of the
united states like if you just like
in no particular state what are like
what down ballot races right now are you
most interested in
really for me it's the ones that could
flip the senate to democrats so
you know i mean certainly as a starting
point i'm looking at susan collins in
maine who's facing sarah a challenge
from sarah gideon
i'm looking at martha mcsally in arizona
who's facing a challenge for mark kelly
uh the tom tillis cal cunningham race in
north carolina steve bullock in montana
the joni ernst race in iowa is
interesting jamie harrison versus
lindsey graham
corey gardner looks like he's going to
lose in colorado that that's where my
focus is
yeah um currently at least in my state
we're
we have a race between shelly moore
capital and apology and swearingen
it's been pretty interesting since i
like in the state
like we're not like we have a history of
progressive politics
although like it's been a while since
like an actual like progressive
politician has made it this far
since like we have like joe manchin as
our um current
vp and it's very interesting to see how
this happens uh
yeah i'm interested i mean now i i am
interested to see how that uh
how that goes i think the implications
of for the balance
of power are less significant but an
interesting race nonetheless
he almost had a pretty progressive
person win for our in our um
governor primary but he made it very
close although the polls came down to it
was like about a two
it was like a two percent difference it
was very close hayden what's it like
living in west virginia i've never had
the pleasure of visiting the state and
you know you hear a lot of different
things it
what what's the experience like uh yeah
in the states it's actually pretty
interesting since people usually assume
it's just like backwoods hillbilly areas
right although like in which in all
fairness a lot of the state is like that
although there are two main cities like
morgantown where i live it's like a
college town it's like pretty vibrant um
and there's also charleston which is a
very nice city um
sadly like our population numbers are
going down pretty significantly
throughout most of the state
like i believe we're like the fastest
shrinking states although we do have a
few towns which are growing which is
nice
so like in morgantown for example would
you be able to go
to a are are there like pretentious
third wave coffee shops and stuff
uh yeah there are some interesting
coffee shops um i don't want to like
there's actually one
like relatively close to me like the
tira cafe like they're by the water and
it's like
since there's college students it's like
it's like a bit more of like a younger
audience for those
right areas but like in the like
charleston also has some like more like
semi like hipstery like shops and stuff
although overall it's like like the
population is generally older in the
state
it's like younger people tend to go to
other areas all right well it sounds
like you're doing okay there then
yeah all right hayden appreciate hearing
from you hope to hear from you again
yeah thank you for your time david all
right there is hayden from west virginia
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you
unexpectedly and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman